The problem with our simple multicore system
is that there is no communication when the
value of a shared variable is changed.
The fix is to provide the necessary communications
over a shared bus that's watched by all the
caches.
A cache can then "snoop" on what's happening
in other caches and then update its local
state to be consistent.
The required communications protocol is called
a "cache coherence protocol".
In designing the protocol, we'd like to incur
the communications overhead only when there's
actual sharing in progress, i.e., when multiple
caches have local copies of a shared variable.
To implement a cache coherence protocol, we'll
change the state maintained for each cache
line.
The initial state for all cache lines is INVALID
indicating that the tag and data fields do
not contain up-to-date information.
This corresponds to setting the valid bit
to 0 in our original cache implementation.
When the cache line state is EXCLUSIVE, this
cache has the only copy of those memory locations
and indicates that the local data is the same
as that in main memory.
This corresponds to setting the valid bit
to 1 in our original cache implementation.
If the cache line state is MODIFIED, that
means the cache line data is the sole valid
copy of the data.
This corresponds to setting both the dirty
and valid bits to 1 in our original cache
implementation.
To deal with sharing issues, there's a fourth
state called SHARED that indicates when other
caches may also have a copy of the same unmodified
memory data.
When filling a cache from main memory, other
caches can snoop on the read request and participate
if fulfilling the read request.
If no other cache has the requested data,
the data is fetched from main memory and the
requesting cache sets the state of that cache
line to EXCLUSIVE.
If some other cache has the requested in line
in the EXCLUSIVE or SHARED state, it supplies
the data and asserts the SHARED signal on
the snoopy bus to indicate that more than
one cache now has a copy of the data.
All caches will mark the state of the cache
line as SHARED.
If another cache has a MODIFIED copy of the
cache line, it supplies the changed data,
providing the correct values for the requesting
cache as well as updating the values in main
memory.
Again the SHARED signal is asserted and both
the reading and responding cache will set
the state for that cache line to SHARED.
So, at the end of the read request, if there
are multiple copies of the cache line, they
will all be in the SHARED state.
If there's only one copy of the cache line
it will be in the EXCLUSIVE state.
Writing to a cache line is when the sharing
magic happens.
If there's a cache miss, the first cache performs
a cache line read as described above.
If the cache line is now in the SHARED state,
a write will cause the cache to send an INVALIDATE
message on the snoopy bus,
telling all other caches to invalidate their
copy of the cache line, guaranteeing the local
cache now has EXCLUSIVE access to the cache
line.
If the cache line is in the EXCLUSIVE state
when the write happens, no communication is
necessary.
Now the cache data can be changed and the
cache line state set to MODIFIED, completing
the write.
This protocol is called "MESI" after the first
initials of the possible states.
Note that the the valid and dirty state bits
in our original cache implementation have
been repurposed to encode one of the four
MESI states.
The key to success is that each cache now
knows when a cache line may be shared by another
cache, prompting the necessary communication
when the value of a shared location is changed.
No attempt is made to update shared values,
they're simply invalidated and the other caches
will issue read requests if they need the
value of the shared variable at some future
time.
To support cache coherence, the cache hardware
has to be modified to support two request
streams: one from the CPU and one from the
snoopy bus.
The CPU side includes a queue of store requests
that were delayed by cache misses.
This allows the CPU to proceed without having
to wait for the cache refill operation to
complete.
Note that CPU read requests will need to check
the store queue before they check the cache
to ensure the most-recent value is supplied
to the CPU.
Usually there's a STORE_BARRIER instruction
that stalls the CPU until the store queue
is empty, guaranteeing that all processors
have seen the effect of the writes before
execution resumes.
On the snoopy side, the cache has to snoop
on the transactions from other caches, invalidating
or supplying cache line data as appropriate,
and then updating the local cache line state.
If the cache is busy with, say, a refill operation,
INVALIDATE requests may be queued until they
can be processed.
Usually there's a READ_BARRIER instruction
that stalls the CPU until the invalidate queue
is empty, guaranteeing that updates from other
processors have been applied to the local
cache state before execution resumes.
Note that the "read with intent to modify"
transaction shown here is just protocol shorthand
for a READ immediately followed by an INVALIDATE,
indicating that the requester will be changing
the contents of the cache line.
How do the CPU and snoopy cache requests affect
the cache state?
Here in micro type is a flow chart showing
what happens when.
If you're interested, try following the actions
required to complete various transactions.
Intel, in its wisdom, adds a fifth "F" state,
used to determine which cache will respond
to read requests when the requested cache
line is shared by multiple caches
basically it selects which of the SHARED cache
lines gets to be the responder.
But this is a bit abstract.
Let's try the MESI cache coherence protocol
on our earlier example!
Here are our two threads and their local cache
states indicating that values of locations
X and Y are shared by both caches.
Let's see what happens when the operations
happen in the order (1 through 4) shown here.
You can check what happens when the transactions
are in a different order or happen concurrently.
First, Thread A changes X to 3.
Since this location is marked as SHARED [S]
in the local cache, the cache for core 0 ($_0)
issues an INVALIDATE transaction for location
X to the other caches,
giving it exclusive access to location X,
which it changes to have the value 3.
At the end of this step, the cache for core
1 ($_1) no longer has a copy of the value
for location X.
In step 2, Thread B changes Y to 4.
Since this location is marked as SHARED in
the local cache, cache 1 issues an INVALIDATE
transaction for location Y to the other caches,
giving it exclusive access to location Y,
which it changes to have the value 4.
In step 3, execution continues in Thread B,
which needs the value of location X.
That's a cache miss, so it issues a read request
on the snoopy bus, and cache 0 responds with
its updated value, and both caches mark the
location X as SHARED.
Main memory, which is also watching the snoopy
bus, also updates its copy of the X value.
Finally, in step 4, Thread A needs the value
for Y, which results in a similar transaction
on the snoopy bus.
Note the outcome corresponds exactly to that
produced by the same execution sequence on
a timeshared core
since the coherence protocol guarantees that
no cache has an out-of-date copy of a shared
memory location.
And both caches agree on the ending values
for the shared variables X and Y.
If you try other execution orders, you'll
see that sequential consistency and shared
memory semantics are maintained in each case.
The cache coherency protocol has done it's
job!
Let's summarize our discussion of parallel
processing.
At the moment, it seems that the architecture
of a single core has reached a stable point.
At least with the current ISAs, pipeline depths
are unlikely to increase and out-of-order,
superscalar instruction execution has reached
the point of diminishing performance returns.
So it seems unlikely there will be dramatic
performance improvements due to architectural
changes inside the CPU core.
GPU architectures continue to evolve as they
adapt to new uses in specific application
areas, but they are unlikely to impact general-purpose
computing.
At the system level, the trend is toward increasing
the number of cores and figuring out how to
best exploit parallelism with new algorithms.
Looking further ahead, notice that the brain
is able to accomplish remarkable results using
fairly slow mechanisms
It takes ~.01 seconds to get a message to
the brain and synapses fire somewhere between
0.3 to 1.8 times per second.
Is it massive parallelism that gives the brain
its "computational" power?
Or is it that the brain uses a different computation
model, e.g., neural nets, to decide upon new
actions given new inputs?
At least for applications involving cognition
there are new architectural and technology
frontiers to explore.
You have some interesting challenges ahead
if you get interested in the future of parallel
processing!